es ist wirklich hoch aktuell mein thema
weil ich heute sozusagen die
vollständige
impfung habe also 14 tage nach dem
zweiten termin und es ist halt wirklich
auch das für mich weil ich natürlich
jetzt bei mir auch merkel im gespräch
mit mehreren leuten freunden bekannten
kreisen dass die gespräche über das
impfen inzwischen gar nicht gar keine
vernünftigen gespräche mehr sind sondern
nicht so viel ideologie dahinter ist
dass viele aussagen man sollte
vielleicht gar nicht über politik reden
entsprechend dass das ist für mich ein
problem weil für mich ansichten und und
personen zusammen gehören und ich will
mich nicht mit jemand verstehen können
nur verstehen indem ich bestimmte themen
einfach ausblenden und das ist ein
grüppchen dilemma nämlich bin und darum
habe ich hier gar nicht nur große these
heute abend sondern ich hab ne ich
brauch trat von ihnen allen die man
eigentlich damit umgehen kann das ist
wirklich harte gruppe war jetzt genau
genau wie geht man damit um mittel was
haben sie denn für menschen welche die
sich nicht impfen lassen
klasse also noch wenn jemand wirklich
aus sagt ich habe da gesundheitliche
probleme oder ängste dass das eine aber
da werden wir dann wirklich so richtig
krasse verschwörungstheorien teilweise
erzählt also verschiebung
dann sollen wir mal ihr handy auch werk
leben dann new world order also wirklich
da wird jetzt gerade hier alles geht
eine neue weltordnung verschaffen und
das sind das sind also von leuten denen
ich das auch die erwartete kann erwartet
haben ich bin irritiert richtig ja also
das ist
ich meide die leute zwischen ich kann
mir eine ehre wie geht man mit
querdenkern und weltverschwörung im
freundeskreis um versucht man die zu
überzeugen versucht man sie mit
argumenten zu überzeugen
und da gibt man sie auf ja also man also
ich hab ja sowas schon gespräche auch in
die richtung geführt und ich werde auch
schnell emotional ich hab mir dann auch
so meine denke also ich habe jetzt nicht
warum habe ich mich impfen lassen
natürlich auch selbstschutz aber ich
sehe es ja auch so dass es eine
gemeinschaft ist also wir sind in dieser
gemeinschaft und ich hab auch für die
anderen schuldig gemacht ja und wenn die
leute dann sagen okay wenn ganz viele
leute gemeint ist dann muss ich mich ja
nicht kämpfen sondern leute kenne ich
dann auch ja und der sagt mir wenn alle
so denken dann brauchen wir gar nicht
erst anfangen das ist da was dran ist
also nebenbei den punkt ich würde
antworten mit optimismus jetzt stehen
uns noch mal vor heute vor einem jahr
hätte uns jemand gesagt ich sagt heute
in einem jahr sind 70 prozent der
europäer mit einem supermodernen
impfstoff durchgeimpft und es kommt eine
vierte welle und die macht nichts mehr
da hätten ihr vor einem jahr gesagt
träumen weiter also so gut kann die
pandemie nicht ausgehen eigentlich sind
wir doch in eine also jetzt so guten
position wenn wir mal zwei jahren gesagt
mensch diese keine schlechte science
fiction natürlich
aber trotzdem finde ich wenn man über
das impfen redet ist das eigentlich eine
tolle erfolgsgeschichte also nicht nur
von der wissenschaft auch von der
wirtschaft wie sie es umgesetzt habe und
dann auch die verteilung in europa ich
bin in den letzten wochen viel in europa
umkreist und irland meldet ein foto von
90 prozent dänemark von 90 prozent malta
hat jetzt glaube ich sogar 93 prozent
heute die spanier die portugiesen aber
das ist ja wo sind das heißt wenn sie so
hoch empfunden haben ist die pandemie
vorbei und deswegen hat er dänemark
jetzt auch erklärt nicht nur für freedom
day sondern die panini ist zu ende und
wir kommen da jetzt raus dadurch und
wenn es dann park werden hier gibt sie
irgendwie rumspinnen da würde ich sagen
ja gut die können wir verkraften weil
das ist die frage sie sind auch sehr
diskussionsfreudig wie ich heute abend
gemerkt habe und dann würde ich wirklich
dringend dazu raten jetzt auch gerade
nach anderthalb jahren wo man so ein
bisschen in so einem eigenen kopf einer
eigenen blase gelebt hat nehmen sie die
diskussion an jetzt kriegen sie hin
marschieren sie los ich glaube es gibt
viele gute argumente die wir gerade
gehört haben von dann weimar und dessau
inflation ist auch schon will aber
die argumente selbst die lage ändert
sich schlüssig dafür sind werden als
argumente für deren also inzwischen ist
es so komisch gekippt ist ja wohl in
einer eigenen welt wieso haben wir eine
kleine blase ist wir leben ja nicht nur
komisch
rat geben aber ich glaube angesichts des
beschriebenen zustand 70 prozent zweiter
ist vielleicht liebevolles ignorieren ja
ja also die eigene die eigene
diskussionslos zügel liebevolles
irgendwie außer es gibt keinen grund für
liebevoll dann weg ich sage mir immer
habe ich euch überschätzt die ganzen
jahre weil es für dich sagen ja denn
genau zu wissen und damit eventuell
freundschaften in gefahr zu bringen aber
ja natürlich haben sie die überschätzt
für mich zum beispiel wäre das wirklich
ein grund eine freundschaft zu
überdenken weil ich dann denken müsste
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du noch alle
tassen im schrank hast also wenn mir
jemand erzählt von münchen und dem chip
und legt man das handy weg ich weiß
nicht ob ich dann in dieser freundschaft
noch so viele parallelen und auch
vertrauen in diese person den rat dieser
person
und wenn die person diese beiden
argumente nur denkt und nicht sagt und
einfach sagt ich will es nicht der
wirkliche freundschaft auch nicht wenn
jemand sagt ich will regieren lassen
dann müsste man ändern er würde gar
nichts unaufrichtig mir gegenüber weil
dann will ich fragen was hast du denn
für grüne dich nicht impfen zu lassen
und dann sagt mir nicht verrate ich hier
nicht also habe ich momentan wirklich
derjenige halte ich weiß nicht
vielleicht doch gemacht und wir machen
es wie der irische premierminister der
wurde wenig aufgegriffen die ganzen
zweifel dazu und er hat gesagt wir
machen einen wettbewerb wer wird mehr
gekämpft die briten oder die iren und
dann waren auch in riehen so
aber so
von der bundesregierung
gegen
dortmund gegen schalke hannover
gegen nürnberg werde ich meine dass das
wären ja doch im grunde in der kampagne
gewesen stattdessen haben wir gesagt
wenn ihr euch nicht impfen das müssen
alle starb das ist irgendwie finden der
fall
man darf die nicht aufgeben also ich
würde wirklich gern widersprechen wir
haben vielleicht der großteil von uns
hier in der runde das glück gehabt dass
wir in familien leben konnten dass wir
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr platz
gehabt haben es habe beim menschen
gegeben die haben die letzten 18 jahre
aus dem home office heraus vielleicht
alleinstehend in zwei zimmer wohnungen
verbracht wo im jahre
1818 jahren wäre ich als sonst an der
oberfläche
des 40
das ist richtig aber da ich glaube da
ist der eine oder andere ja auch gar
nicht mehr einem austausch gewesen und
ich würde die nicht aufgeben wenn sie
lange mit denen befreundet waren das
gibt doch immer mal so ein sonnen punkte
in der freundschaft der nicht leicht ist
aber das macht seine freundschaft
geradeaus eine gute freundschaft dass
man sich dann der der anderen person
annimmt und sagt so jetzt ringen heute
abend ein bier- oder in friedrichshain
in china oder was weiß ich was dann
gehen sie hin setzen sich zusammen und
reden noch mal ganz in ruhe vielleicht
sind sie am ende des abends nicht
überzeugt aber wenn der dass zwei oder
drei oder viermal das erlebnis hat
wieder unter menschen sitzt gleich kommt
dann doch noch irgendwie freut sich so
haus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]